with more on the most recent school
shooting the parents of the accused
school shooter ethan crumley could be
charged as soon as today crumbly who is
15 years old has been charged as an
adult for allegedly killing four
students and injuring seven other people
at his oxford michigan high school in a
statement the school superintendent said
it still looks like a war zone and it
will be weeks before students can return
nancy chen is in oxford michigan
following the investigation nancy good
morning
nate good morning to you the county
prosecutor here told me that the
suspect's parents should have done a
better job of securing the weapon that
was used in tuesday's attack and that
could have saved lives
100 percent it could have been prevented
oakland county prosecutor kara mcdonald
said justice is the reason her office
charged the alleged shooter ethan
crumbly with 24 felony charges including
one count of terrorism what's behind
that charge it speaks for what really
happened this is not something that just
happened to to eight individuals this is
the footprint is large
and it has a ripple effect
we hear something that sounds like
someone being punched against a locker
seventeen-year-old catalina ifkovitz
credits her math teacher for saving
lives on tuesday the shooter was right
outside her classroom he was able to
shut the door immediately and get us all
in the lockdown mode if it hadn't been
for the teachers i don't know how many
more casualties there would have been to
say that i am
still
in shock and numb is probably an
understatement last night oxford
community schools superintendent tim
thorn addressed the shooting in victims
we have
parents that sent their kids to school
two days ago
and they're never coming home police say
the shooter used a semi-automatic
handgun purchased by his father just
days before tuesday's attack mcdonald is
investigating the alleged gunman's
parents for possible charges and what
could those potential charges look like
it went far beyond just a negligent
parent and
fully support and advocate holding them
responsible if that meets the
threshold and and the elements are there
and law enforcement officials tell us
that so far the parents are not
cooperating the suspect has pleaded not
guilty on all charges the superintendent
also did say that there are no prior
disciplinary actions against the alleged
shooter even after a meeting on his
behavior just hours before the shooting
michelle
so much coming out of this nancy thank
you for your reporting